just noobs oh boy casual I'll do one
blindfold one non blindfold let's get
some some voice practice my type anymore
let's play on let's play a deep I'm some
scan d yeah turn down the volume if I
can find it I'd see three I'll take on
d5 yeah 25
pre-move yeah this is it's a pleasant
opening if especially when white doesn't
know the theory this is already
preferable for black the queen is well
placed in the center Bishop c4 pinning
the Knights attacking the knight with
both the bishop and the Queen you should
be too I'll play knight c6 and the
planter to castle probably Queen side
and then eventually play e5 you five
hurt you six not sure five ideas of
efore ideas of Bishop d6 as well h3
let's play h5 it's a go to fishing pole
trap idea if pawn takes Bishop plan
takes pawn
open the each file have some fun so
waits a bit lagging with development
because uh pawns on D 2 and C 3 he
blocked the bishop and mites on the
Queen side opponent accepting my gifts
h2 okay so my G pawns attacked three
times the night that bishop in the Queen
at five defending the pawn
creating a mini pawn chain d3 so it's
time to develop the bishop probably to
d6 still lining with the Knights like
the rook on h8 the bishop on d6 are
coordinating they have a focal points
whoa
so white sacking back the sack back do I
even want to take that directive I want
to play e4 and just make things insane
probably for is Bishop h3 yeah let's
take f g4 wait FG for Queen D G for King
know what's happening what just happened
wait I've a pawn on e5 Queen on d5 the
Queen on g7 opponent's being somewhat
greedy I think I'll play E for
unleashing the bishop attacking the D
pawn oh wait a minute
I had rook g8 and rook c8 the g2 is the
target - and so focus on each - but e4
still Pleasant before also opens up my
queen so come to h5 which could be
somewhat devastating for white or Wow de
for Bishop H - oh there's a nice meeting
sequence I think King h1 and then
being a challenge yeah king h1 Bishop
chief three recheck and then rook h1
after Kim Jiwan this is nice
I'll Sakura
there's a few differently olders for
whites okay rook h1 we have to make sure
beam each to what green age wait where's
the two one two wait now I'm scared
Queen age too nope no no no no no no aah
take back please I don't know if they'll
offer to take back are you serious
I forgot the difference between the two
and three oh it's so defeating sorry to
my neighbors if I made a loud noise
opponent mystified point so mystified
the game just stopped
but I do now I have a bishop on g3
minutes 45 seconds
I just lost my strongest two pieces my
rook and my queen I'd made them one
should be five recovery the goal is to
play if any hope you know it's so bad
that's an actual boat as gambit
it's a blindfold boat s gambit rook a d1
wait do I have a knight wait so the pawn
is the pawn from g2 went to h3 so I only
have a knight bishop in York left that's
so unfortunate
kingi - Kim G - hmm maybe six
my only hope is like time I guess that's
promising
let's go ooh see oh there's tactics good
move
well played five where's the Queen on g7
nighttime a5 Bishop Sanji five Kings on
G to Brookstone d6 da check the bishop
defends are taking d7 g7 so I only have
a rook and knight to work with this
might be my only blindfold game so
frustrating should f4 seven white one
minute 2 second okay I'm making progress
black 3 minutes 11 seconds rook f8 okay
I fit
hey rook huh for roof takes f4
roof takes f7 row gauge for
hmm g5 king a 6 e 6 trying to remember
where the queenside ponds are flights
Avila pond III
that's not good King a5 that's really
not good
Queen g5 check g5 check oh the whole
rink is open can a Florida for Queen
takes h4 check oh man q5 95 d7 b 5e d 4
months - Queen B 4
Queen takes b4 check oh dear King e6 we
need b5 checkmate oh so shiny so so why
this victorious King that wasn't ready
okay
might see eight thanks for the sympathy
between age three I knew like I knew
there's a the squiggly key look at this
keyboard oh you're waiting for me to
take back no like I've made extra
certain that like I was pressing too but
the squiggly he existed before the one
key I'd show it but it's like yeah maybe
people can kind of see there's a
squiggly key under the Escape key anyway
I'm so unfortunate
I was such a beautiful man yeah - it's
so beautiful
rosin rage yeah I should break something
you know I'll resist from that maybe
I'll put that on YouTube all very much
reluctantly put this on youtube
blindfold botas gambled checkmate fail
we can get more ups in the comments